hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you who what's
going on how are you I'm in Chicago my
kind of town Chicago is my kind of town
Chicago is eating heart-attack food
Chicago is a great place to put on 40
pounds it's my kind of town
yeah oligo steaks chops deep-dish pizza
you know remember that old SNL sketch
when they all dressed like Mike Ditka
and they all having [ __ ] heart
attacks and stuff yeah
this ends my six straight weekends on
the road and I got to tell you I was in
such great shape at the beginning of it
and now I'm starting to go in the wrong
direction so it starts tonight I just
ordered a little bit of room service
something healthy something not so
healthy but uh I'm [ __ ] I got two
shows tonight I was gonna go home as you
can tell I'm fighting off a [ __ ] cold
they'd almost ruined my show last night
in Madison Square Garden thank you to
everybody who showed up I had a great
goddamn town time the sound was
incredible and I had a bunch of friends
came out saw it Mayo like oh my god we
really enjoyed it which made me feel
good thank you to the people you know
some people gave me some gifts you know
I got some cigars this week thank you to
everybody came out to the efforts for
family the thingamajig there that I did
at the Paley Center with Mike Price and
Peter Billingsley we actually aired the
first episode for the people that were
there
we actually got a great review from
Forbes magazine about our third season
saying it's our best [ __ ] season and
and one of the top half hours on Netflix
I mean I am having a hell of a week I
really am I'm enjoying myself but I'm
eating like a [ __ ] it
so drinking this stupid ass [ __ ]
vitamin C [ __ ] you know though just keep
drinking those packets it's like well
it's a thousand milligrams
what drink two of them that's why I'd
really want two thousand of anything in
me that sir seems a leg of like a lot
can you OD on vitamin C you know how
many times can the cold virus kick
vitamin C's ass before we realize that
it really doesn't do anything
vitamin C overdose you know somebody did
this okay for adults the recommended
daily amount for vitamin C's 65 to 90
milligrams now what do I got I got a
thousand milligrams and the upper limit
is two thousand milligrams a day
although too much dietary vitamin C is
unlikely to be harmful mega doses of
vitamin C supplements might cause
diarrhea or nausea okay we can't OD on
it [ __ ] hilarious if you get so into
health that you [ __ ] overdosed the
ugly truth behind the vitamin C overdose
well according to spoon University that
they like to snuggle when they learn
things spoon University I hate being
sick and I'm guessing you do too says
the article above Shamo so you've hurt
someone you can never take too much
vitamin C is that really too true or is
it a myth
can we overdose environments I don't
care I don't care [ __ ] if I'm reading
just say the answer I'm gonna read an
episode of a [ __ ] television show
that doesn't exist it's not an old
person reading a book the other day at
the airport it was just like wow that's
[ __ ] amazing you know they just
didn't give in wasn't staring at a
[ __ ] smartphone like everybody else
including myself you know I actually use
my smartphone which I helped me with my
stress
whenever I'm stressing out I just play
[ __ ] solitaire you know
it's got a nice [ __ ] mellow guitar
thing wait wait where but not where all
this [ __ ] song it plays in the
background I just don't give a [ __ ] try
to beat my top score you know and I look
up I'm strolling at the airport I don't
give a [ __ ] I really dump you know what
I hate I hate when these [ __ ] near
the [ __ ] security line at the airport
and some [ __ ] [ __ ] behind you goes
okay just get through them sorry but my
flights already boarding it's just like
okay well you're [ __ ] gonna miss it
then now because you're late because
you're late you get rewarded for being
late by not having to wait in the
[ __ ] line like the rest of us [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you and [ __ ] your flight you
know I'm sorry could I just in in this
stupid body language they're trying to
be all like submissive as they walk past
you I mean what's to stop somebody from
just saying my flight leaves in [ __ ]
10 minutes I mean that's the move if you
don't have TSA PreCheck or global or you
know he didn't have you eight ain't
mapped whatever the [ __ ] they're doing
now to get you on the plane sooner I
mean that's the move I think your
conspiracy theorist and you don't want
them to have any more information about
you but you don't like waiting in lines
I would just show up say I'm sorry might
make my flight leaves in ten minutes can
I just can I just you know somebody's
give those people the all right there
Fred
oh god I'm [ __ ] miserable
if I can somehow do these two shows
tonight and not get sick but I can just
fight it off but anyways I had the
greatest [ __ ] night ever last night
just wired a wire I just had a [ __ ]
awesome set and then the after-party was
at Gotham comedy club with the Mazzilli
so I've known forever and they made this
incredible cake
I believe they got the Cake Boss to make
it we took pictures I uploaded and [ __ ]
but it was uh it was the cake was not
only Madison Square Garden it also
looked like a snare drum because you
know obviously I played drums there was
a helicopter on it
and then they had this big figurine of
me wearing that [ __ ] shirt I wore in
my last special with the stars on it and
then they had the John Bonham's green
sparkle 1971 Ludwig kick you know what
this little Zeppelin four insignia on it
it was incredible
[ __ ] cake was incredible and they les
well I can't see what they let us do
because I don't think they get them into
[ __ ] trouble but you know something
they usually make you do outside they
allowed us to do inside which was
[ __ ] tremendous and that was it then
I [ __ ] went home and now I'm in
Chicago I'm in [ __ ] Chicago I got
four shows here and the Chicago Theatre
which arguably has the greatest marquee
in the country I feel speaking of the
greatest Paul virzi special thanks to
you guys is it's one of the
highest-rated specials Comedy Central's
had in a long time
it's [ __ ] crushing it has over like a
million views so thank you to everybody
who went out and watched it it's still
streaming on Comedy Central you can
check it out it's great for Paul it's
great for me because he did it with my
company all things comedy mine and Al
madrigals you know it's [ __ ]
tremendous that's the first one and you
know what we got three more coming if
you think Paul firs he was was was the
high-water mark and we're gonna dip nope
everybody's is gonna be at the same
[ __ ] level it's all gonna be quality
do I sound like Trump right now ice
actually watched a little bit of that
news conference by the way you know that
childish [ __ ] affair Jesus Christ
everybody is yelling at each other
reporter continuing to ask questions
it's Trump saying I'm done with you if
then he walked away from the microphone
that whole [ __ ] thing on both sides
was like embarrassing and I am NOT a fan
of Trump but for people to sit there and
act like the media does not [ __ ]
absolutely hate that [ __ ] guy I've
never seen I mean I've never seen a guy
get
can attacked the way this [ __ ] dude
gets attacked it's like watching a comic
play a hell room it's just up there
getting [ __ ] heckled he's like I'm
not gonna do my [ __ ] actor I'll go do
my act yeah you [ __ ] suck I don't
know it's the worst job on the [ __ ]
plane you literally get blamed for
everything you know why don't why don't
they [ __ ] have a press conference
with some of these [ __ ] piece-of-shit
corporations pollute in the water
stealing from people blowing up the
economy and then ripping the rug out
from every what the [ __ ] about them you
become president you just you just their
[ __ ] stooge and you go out there and
you stand there and you just get yelled
at by these [ __ ] nerds who think
they're in the Paper Chase or some [ __ ]
I have no idea another [ __ ] bad story
it's just a bad you know I just put on
the TV and I saw that whole thing about
the [ __ ] one of those mass shootings
things and it just makes no sense that
those things happen all the time other
than the fact that that's all they
[ __ ] show on TV and there has to be
some sort of connection to that because
there's always been a [ __ ] load of guns
and a [ __ ] load of people that had them
and I literally think like it's like the
ice bucket challenge for psychos they
just [ __ ] member that everybody saw
everybody doing the ice bucket challenge
so then everybody had to start dumping
[ __ ] water over their heads instead
of just giving money I never understood
that it's like what is the cause okay
that's a good cause I mean I don't have
to ruin my shirt for it do it would you
like some money I'm willing to give you
some so I would love to see if they
could experiment just not giving it any
coverage and then it would just fade
away like an old pop star I think you
know I don't know that's my - because
other than that that I don't have any
[ __ ] solution for it just [ __ ]
horrific how anybody could [ __ ] do
something like that
but anyways back to the comedy back to
the comedy oh my god this is one of
these [ __ ] days some days doing a
podcast is easy you know it's like
falling out of bed well it's not a
[ __ ] for one thing is it's like
getting out of bed rolling out of bed
it's like taking a nap is that an easy
thing we ask people hundred people get a
survey said name the top five things are
easy yeah you know bad I would suck on
[ __ ] the family food I can't say the
name of show the family feud
name something that's easy to do mr.
burr fall out of bed show me fall out of
bed and Sullivan family with a chance to
steal I'd be that last family member you
know what I mean [ __ ] do it all the
way down the end you know families only
have so many smart people and it seems
when you watch the family feud
it stops around three is if five people
on it shows always the last two you know
somebody always just said something that
sucks well you should really do I think
well how would you do that it's almost
like a batting lineup with intelligence
okay cuz you got to have your leadoff
hitter you know you gotta have somebody
bat and clean up and then you get you
know you got your pitcher bat and knife
if we're if we're going by national
league rules here right what do you do
do you put the dummy up front when all
the answers are still on the board name
a word that begins with a but Apple Bing
number-one answer right or do you just
leave that guy down the end and hope
that everybody else you know does a good
job I wonder if this fights you know
when somebody finds out yeah hey we're
gonna have you all the way down to the
end basically the right field of
intelligence we're gonna have you all
the way down the [ __ ] in now it's the
person too stupid to realize that that's
where the dumbest person is you know
anyway everybody needs to get a hit
everybody needs to get ahead because
this [ __ ] gonna
get a strike all right just put him all
the [ __ ] way down he's gonna get the
least at-bats in theory but up up up up
they should have a [ __ ] a week of all
those [ __ ] people down the ends you
know you just make super families out of
that last person just the dumbest
[ __ ] ever Oh would you call it
a family feud [ __ ] dope week
whoo Oh set shows is still Steve Harvey
he would probably run out of looks to
give the crowd anyway so I'm here in
Chicago this bucket and I got a I got a
I got to get back on my goddamn diet you
know I was looking good before I did
this six-week run I had my whole [ __ ]
future ahead of me you know it's [ __ ]
hilarious I'm going to the heart doctor
next week to get my ticker checked out
six weeks ago I began phenomenal shape
for your age there's gonna be like a
probably lose seven pounds I could do it
though I'm gonna be that you know what
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be that [ __ ]
guy that loses weight during the
holidays you know there's only one way
to do that you got to be homeless nobody
loves you cuz I don't care how much of
an [ __ ] you are when it's the
holidays somebody's gonna make cookies
right those stupid little tins you walk
over you open it up you know is that
voice in the back your head what are you
doing what are you doing and then you
shout it down with you know I'm gonna go
to the gym in January I'm gonna start
the year with a giant [ __ ] steamship
round for a [ __ ] tour so I can't do
it man
I'm disgusted with myself look what you
did bill you had a good thing going you
[ __ ] ruined it I haven't watched any
sports I didn't know what's going on
anymore right Red Sox won the World
Series and I just been [ __ ] flying
high I haven't watched anything I know
the late what about [ __ ] Duke just
absolutely kicking the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of Kentucky yeah once again once again
they got it they got another guy how do
they [ __ ] do it Duke verse Kentucky
now how does that work do they just have
this [ __ ] just to like for the ratings
so they can figure out who's who's the
best team does this actually count is it
like soccer where they have a friendly
shut up you know the soccer is like
they're you know we're playing but it
doesn't doesn't mean anything that's 75
47 with 14 minutes to go are you [ __ ]
kidding me
they scored 75 points and a half and it
just can't be it can't be 118 to 84
that's like a [ __ ] NBA score they
still let up 84 points though I don't
know I don't know how to [ __ ] that works
but it did somehow I'll tell you what
they've Duke Blue Devils they put
equipment on that [ __ ] Wildcats from
Kentucky all right let me do a couple of
reads here everybody Southie everyone at
some point is wish they could just have
a just have beer wine or liquor
delivered well someone finally decided
to do something about it
introducing stuffy the alcohol delivery
app Safi delivers your favorite wine
beer and liquor right to you Dilla on
demand now filled now if you live in Los
Angeles the Bay Area Chicago San Diego
or Sacramento you're thought they order
will arrive at you Dilla and under 30
minutes ready to drink now why didn't
they say Los Angeles
the Bay Area San Diego Sacramento and
then Chicago this is how long I've been
on the tour like that [ __ ] routing
sucks I mean LA I go up to San Francisco
Oakland then I go over to Chicago back
to San Diego and up to Sacramento the
[ __ ] are we doing here for the rest of
us saathi will deliver beer wine and
liquor to you Dilla in two days or less
nationwide there are no order minimums
no delivery fees no running to the
Steaua if you got the saucy app you got
a fully stocked by on your phone and for
a limited time you can get $15 off when
you down wait I'm in Chicago they can
deliver me something my kind of booze
with saucy baby we deliver to LA and
[ __ ] saucy and [ __ ] in the Bay Area
there are no order minimums no delivery
fees no running to the store if you got
the saucy app you got a fully stocked
bar on your phone and for a limited time
you can you can get $15 off when you
download this saucy happen enter promo
code bar that saucy app spelled sauc ey
unit to the promo code bar P you are off
450 nose off get the saucy app today and
use promo code burn oh look who's here
but who do do me undies me undies eat
enough [ __ ] steak doo-doo-doo-doo me
undies me undies it's fall grab a rake
eat a bunch of pizza and [ __ ]
fattening food walk around like a
mustachioed dude cuz you're in Chicago
block your arteries with all their
[ __ ] delicious food and none of its
healthy while your balls roll around on
felt me undies uses the coveted micro
motile modal fabric which is three times
softer than cotton if you never felt
this fabric get ready to experience pure
bliss in underwear form men and women
can choose from four different cuts all
of which are available from classic
colors to adventurous
prince speaking of prince this holiday
season oh the holiday season me undies
will be releasing a new [ __ ] print
every goddamn Tuesday that means you
have no excuse to celebrate the holidays
right down to your very own car but why
stop at undies this year me undies is
launching their holiday prints and
lounge pants and onesies as well both
are made from the same micro Modell
modal fabric as their undies seriously
how could he get not but how can you not
get you and your loved one a matching
holiday themed onesie this year because
it's kind of weird to be an adult
wearing a [ __ ] onesie you'd be one of
those adult babies you know sitting a
[ __ ] crib because you can't deal with
reality well I guess you know that's
just another segment of the population
they're trying to make money off of so
you know god bless him the undies has a
great offer from my listeners for
first-time purchasers purchase yours
when you purchase any me undies you get
50% off and free shipping this is a
no-brainer get 50% off the most
comfortable on these you will ever put
on to get you 50% off your first pair of
free shipping and hundred-percent
satisfaction guarantee
go to me undies dot-com / / that's me
undies dot-com / bar all right what's
left o butcher box
alright butcher bucks that reminds me I
looked up battle axe today this is the
[ __ ] funny thing after I try to talk
to that [ __ ] battle axe over there
you know I always thought that meant an
ugly woman it just means a woman who
doesn't take any [ __ ] she's difficult
right you know I don't know I always
thought like a battle axe it looked bad
it was all [ __ ] up looking because she
went to battle on it so you've seen her
face look like a battle axe I guess it
wasn't though they determined let's look
up the definition of battle axe shall we
my god call your wife that and see what
the [ __ ] happens yeah yeah [ __ ]
battle axe
alright battle-ax meaning is a term
generally considered a pejorative do you
how many times I've looked up pejorative
that's like when they said the Democrats
won the house I was like oh my god what
does that mean every election I have to
look up what does the [ __ ] house do
versus what does the Senate do I thought
they were all on the old is at the
capital there's one side the house the
other sides the Senate I don't know one
of you I just picture you go in there
and all you hear is the sound of loafers
walking on marble all right expressing
contempt or disapproval pejorative can
you use it an express entance please
know it gives a [ __ ] I don't even care
anymore right a battle-axe even [ __ ]
battle-ax where is it okay so it's well
what just happened oh there it is all
right a battle-axe is a term generally
considered pejorative for an aggressive
domineering and forceful woman no this
is the female word for [ __ ] guy's
a dick she's a [ __ ] battle-ax he's a
[ __ ] dick
battle-ax is just funnier the battle-ax
is one of several stereotypes found in
nursing a tyrannical fierce matron
exemplified by nurse ratchet or Hades
Jacques in popular medical dramas and
comedies I have why the [ __ ] is why is
everybody picking on nurses I don't know
it's kind of my goal this week I'm gonna
call somebody a battle-axe I would never
call my wife that she's too [ __ ] cute
what's the worst thing I have called my
wife
I don't call I don't I don't do the name
call I think most other we stop being
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] leave me alone
[Laughter]
just leave me alone all right all right
put your box everybody butcher box
delivers healthy 100% grass-fed and
grass-finished beef free-range organic
chicken and oh heritage bread pork oh do
you owe it to yourself to eat one of
those [ __ ] pigs
the incredible quality of butcher box
meats start with the commitment to
raising animals humanely free of
antibiotics and hormones before they
murder them each box comes with at least
8 to 11 pounds of meat which is enough
for 24 individual size meals or one and
a half meals for a binge eater when
those little skinny Asian guys that for
some reason when the hot dog eating
contest right and the big fat dude can't
can't get it done you can choose from
five different box types all beef beef
and chicken beef and pork mix box or
custom box which lets you choose your
own cuts all right
personal experience I already told you
guys told you many times that heritage
bread pork mean it's pure bread it's
like it's the original pigs from Europe
for whatever reason they taste better
than the ones we got over here you know
probably because our pigs are out eating
[ __ ] McDonald's you know grew up on
peanut butter and fluffernutter or some
[ __ ] I don't know what the hell he's
[ __ ] but he goddamn heritage bread
pork we're doing but whatever they did
it they they taste [ __ ] delicious
anyways for $20 off your first box and
two pounds of free ground beef in every
box for the life of your subscription
that's $20 off your first box and two
pounds of free meat a month that's a lot
of [ __ ] meat quarter-pounder right
that'd be a quarter pounders how many
days are in a month well-built depends
on the month alright relax and for
people who are already butcher box
subscribers you'll have a special deal
on ground beef you can take advantage of
by logging into your account go to butch
butcher box com slash burger
and enter promo code burn and check out
once again butcher box calm / / and
enter burn at checkout okay alright
let's get back to this [ __ ] [ __ ]
over here let me sum I see you know I'm
gonna look at this is just I like search
and dump [ __ ] like this top 10 worst
things you can call your girlfriend here
we go I just popped up alright let's see
what we got here but up but up buzz
let's play the feud
alright out let's see my top 10 number
one would be [ __ ] number two would be
[ __ ] [ __ ] got to be in there [ __ ]
battle-ax heifer Jesus Christ that's all
I got that's got me something else what
else good call you [ __ ] uh this kind
of covers it right bimbo dumb-dumb I'm
just run she's becoming a [ __ ] second
grader alright the 10 worst things you
can call a female whom a sis list well
how did I end up looking this up what
the [ __ ] is on the 10th worst things you
can call a woman number 10 [ __ ] this is
probably the most common term used
straighten to the point yet known as
degrading because of its immense
popularity in common use well it depends
on on yeah like I think if black women
if you call them a [ __ ] it mean and
it's means more white women for some
reason white women really don't like
[ __ ] and I think white people say [ __ ] a
lot I don't know that black people say
[ __ ] which would be [ __ ] hilarious
at least American black people I haven't
seen it you know now like I'm out here
doing a [ __ ] survey but I'm just
generally speaking the people I talk to
anyways I find black people will add you
know add to [ __ ] stank [ __ ] or
something like that but they never seem
to make the leap to cut
the white people like [ __ ] just sad
she's a [ __ ] you know but what she's
really being a [ __ ] she's a [ __ ] and
that's how it works everybody all right
number nine cow
speaking of butcher bucks cow the only
reason this is so low on the list is
because it never comes as a surprise a
fat chick knows she's a fat child Jesus
Christ she know she's a fat chick in
fact sometimes they even embrace it
so in rare cases that's gonna actually
backfire now I don't think I don't think
this works I don't I don't I don't
believe in that and who wants to be
called a [ __ ] cow that is funny
though
you [ __ ] cow cows funnier than Pig
what do you say you fat pig you're fat
cow there's something about cow maybe
it's the sound it says oh you know this
I was in there it hurts it's a hurtful
thing [ __ ] number seven horse lash ho
number six is slob wait a second I
didn't mind when you called me a [ __ ]
but when you said I was a slob that was
it skank Pig bimbo [ __ ] smut bag oh this
is worse than my list and then [ __ ] yeah
you knew cut was gonna be number one all
right now let's nuts to be fair let's be
fair to the ladies here all right
top ten worst things you can call your
boyfriend this is how you kill time on
the road as a comedian by the way
alright this is hilarious women have 25
things that they call guys they really
do talk more don't they 25 worst pet
names for your lover things you don't
want to call your lover 50 horrible
nicknames for your significant the 13
worst pet names what not to say to your
boyfriend all right here we go
I would imagine when he takes his dick
out they go is that it it tickles all
right number one you're so much better
than all the other jerks I've dated yeah
because that makes them immediate thing
quell how much [ __ ] has been in you can
you really afford that this is just one
of these classic things it's like did
they even ask guys can you really afford
that can really afford that yeah I can
or no I can't thank you for stopping me
for making this bad purchase that seems
like a concerned girlfriend so we're
running a little late
relax all right so running a little late
comes with the territory but if there's
a pre-emptive relaxed before I flipped
out that would bug me although I don't
know if this makes my top ten he's a
great guy you should be friends with him
yeah that means you guys used to [ __ ]
are you about ready to number five she
made me promise not to tell but that's
not surprising then you can keep your
[ __ ] mouth shut
cloten guys number six don't be silly I
haven't done that in ages I don't know
what that means
what are we talking about you want some
heroin don't be silly I haven't done
that in ages
okay put it in your ass don't be silly I
haven't done that in ages so yeah that's
kind of a weird answer no matter what
you were asked would you like some
cereal don't be silly I haven't done
that in ages
anyways number ten
Oh ten sentences he be psyched to hear
number one boy nothing helps me wind
down after a long day at work like
giving you a blow job
okay that's never been said number 2
monoamine know what this became like
wacky dick jokes
alright that was Cosmo everybody all
right I need to drink more [ __ ] I
guess vitamin C it's inevitable okay I
got to do two shows tonight all right
old freckles is gonna get sick first
cold of the Year didn't even make it to
[ __ ] in December you know all right well
thank you once again to everybody who
came out to Madison Square Garden thank
you to Gotham comedy club for the
after-party thank you for to the
Westside comedy club for helping me tune
up my [ __ ] earlier in the week and uh I
think that said take it up a tree showed
up all right enjoy the music and they
continued special half-hour of I guess
greatest hits from a Thursday podcast
from earlier this year or 10 years ago I
have no idea oh by the way I got some
great [ __ ] video too backstage that
we will be putting up on the patreon
page from the beginning of the show and
the end of the show very excited about
it
that is all have a great weekend you
[ __ ] I can't say contrite I don't
know Fedya right
huh you slobs who are you not gonna
listen to the podcast anymore Michael
[ __ ] yourself see
my
[Music]
I never laid a hand on you
like a million miles away from me you
couldn't see how I adored you
so close so close and yet
[Music]
carry your books from school
baby look at you now you just got your
asses whipped by a bunch of goddamn
nerds well if I was you I'd do something
about it I would get up and redeem
myself in the eyes of my father my maker
and my coach hey it's bill burr it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday
November 8 2010 hope these levels aren't
too [ __ ] high I had to really crank
that up so you could actually hear that
speech that I hope there's actually some
New England Patriots listening that
without that goes out to the New England
Patriots everybody after that [ __ ]
shellacking that rape today that they
took at the hands of the [ __ ] hapless
Cleveland Browns
the [ __ ] hapless Cleveland Browns why
these levels so [ __ ] high hang on a
second hang on hang on hang on what's
going on here hello hello test one to
bill per our Monday morning podcast
there we go is that better is that
better Jesus Christ we got [ __ ]
killed absolutely [ __ ] killed by a
white running back everybody
you know something I'm gonna go out on a
limb I think the white running back or
fullback let's not get crazy now let's
not get crazy the full-back that [ __ ]
white dude who just doesn't feel pain
I'll [ __ ] kill him
that guy that dude is back [ __ ]
remember that [ __ ] white dude who
rode the bull in blazing Saddles put a
helmet on that guy that's who the
[ __ ] Pats went up against yesterday
Jesus Christ you should have seen this
[ __ ] guy he had a face mask his face
mask looked like the front of a Dodge
Ram pickup truck look like the grille of
that Dodge Ram pickup truck the second
you see his face mask you know what he's
doing he's getting the ball he's going
right up the [ __ ] middle he's not
running around the side like some fairy
[ __ ] running back he's coming right
up to a [ __ ] gut and that's exactly
what that guy did all goddamn day long
he was stiff-arming defensive ends like
they were corner backs just sort of
throwing him aside it was it was one of
the most dominating performances that
I've seen in a while and so that was a
little inspirational [ __ ] speech for
my team because next week we're playing
the pittsburgh's and I was already
worried about that game but uh this is
the interesting thing about how football
works is if the Patriots went in and
actually beat the Browns
I was thinking that okay if we beat the
Browns and then we go up seven and one
we are gonna get up what happened in
Cleveland was gonna happen in Pittsburgh
but now for some [ __ ] reason this is
how it seems to work that we lost in
Cleveland will actually be way more
competitive I still think we're gonna
lose in Pittsburgh our defense is
[ __ ] horrific it's horrific
you know it's [ __ ] frustrating to be
going through you know it's actually not
bad we going through a [ __ ] a
rebuilding year you know and I know a
lot of you guys out there just because
it's the Patriots you still think it's
the [ __ ] championship team go get
yourself a little team roster thing and
look who's left you know my whole
offense is built around thrown to two
rookie [ __ ] tight ends and Brady was
off yesterday he kept throwing
everything through the [ __ ] roof
right I'm sitting there talking to these
people in this sports bar actually found
a cool one where it was kind of mellow
and there wasn't really you know there's
like this insane one around the corner
where people it's just like you can't
even go in there with your team colors
on because if your team is losing that
day you're gonna want to fight somebody
it's one of those places and it's just
not an enjoyable experience so I found
this other one
where they have like nice like you know
it's just nice the decor is nice it
doesn't have that [ __ ] date-rape vibe
like a lot of sports bars do you know
that [ __ ] awful vibe the pent-up just
[ __ ] the the amount of [ __ ] just
pent up
you know and then they got those [ __ ]
girls always got a dress like runaways
the waitresses it's just creepy the
whole [ __ ] vibe is creepy I don't
like it and it's just yeah this is awful
so I found this other sports bar that
was you know actually way more mellow
and I'm sitting there right and I come
walking in by the time I get there it's
it's already tend enough in Cleveland
and I sit down as this dude next to me
already drinking beers the game comes on
at like [ __ ] 10:00 in the morning he's
clearly on like his third beer I didn't
realize he was shit-faced I go Jesus
Christ I go ten to nothing I go I go I
go what happened and he looks at me he's
like Cleveland is up ten nothing just
like all right man thank you thank you
for [ __ ] uh thank you for clearing
that up you know and Jesus Christ and
they just stopped was awful we just got
the living [ __ ] kicked out of him you
know it was funny was last week this
week I got I got ton of emails from Jets
fans it was very surprising because last
week I didn't get any from you know last
week when they lost to the Packers 9 to
nothing at home I got like two emails
from Jets fans and then this week it was
weird
you know cuz I was like wow did did the
Jets fans not exist anymore then this
week all of a sudden I get this whole
avalanche now look I know all jet fans
and all sports fans aren't like that cuz
a lot of you didn't send me emails
either [ __ ] way but those those
[ __ ] sports [ __ ] who [ __ ] lay
in the weeds until their team wins and
then they get out and start talking [ __ ]
you know let me ask you guys this cuz
I've been just sitting here trashing the
Jets all year just let me ask you this
real honestly honestly do you really
think you're gonna win the Superbowl
with that team you know cuz I have such
blind hatred for the [ __ ] Jets after
the [ __ ] talkin that they did at the
beginning of the year honestly do you
really think that that team has what the
[ __ ] it takes alright
set aside y'all seriously geeking out a
victory against the Lions you eked out a
victory against the Dolphins and you
each one out against the Broncos two out
of three of those games were it not for
a bonehead [ __ ] penalty by the other
goddamn team
you know you could have lost one or
maybe both of those to add to you two
[ __ ] losses now if I'm a jet fan I
gotta be thinking know if I'm a jet fan
I gotta be thinking that one thing I got
going for myself is that
nobody is dominating in the AFC nobody
is you know that's the one thing that I
would take I would take pride in the
fact because the Jets have not really
dominated anybody have they
the Patriots but that wasn't until the
second Oh actually was this second half
second out for the second quarter they
did but other than that
I don't know I'm not too impressed I
think that they're [ __ ] offensive line
might be the best in the league and
Sanchez just sits back there in a
[ __ ] lawn chair but I think if they
actually go up against I don't know the
Giants
yeah I just I don't [ __ ] see it you
know what I'm basically saying is that
when Joe Namath finally dies I I hate to
say it I think you guys gonna have to
get him stuffed and mounted so you can
still wheel him out onto the field to
get you to get that he's like you're
Knute Rockne and then he can stick one
of those things on the side of his neck
where yeah well you just pull the
[ __ ] you pull it and the string and
he starts talking I think the Jets are
gonna make a great play I want to kiss
you
you just have it sort of half [ __ ]
shit-faced half inspirational speech oh
Jesus
so next week we play the [ __ ]
Steelers and uh I don't know I don't
know what's gonna happen I think we're
actually gonna have a nice competitive
[ __ ] game with them somehow it makes
no sense
which is why I have to stop [ __ ]
gambling because I gotta admit as much I
couldn't even say it really hurt because
I don't give a [ __ ] about Cleveland and
I also you know it's no surprise that
our defense sucks the game that pissed
me off the most yesterday was the
[ __ ] Kansas City Chiefs game the this
these were my picks yesterday okay I got
this thing going Paul virzi right
you got to pick four games a [ __ ]
week the end of the year the guy takes
the pot right so I got the cheat I got
the I got the bears against Buffalo
Bears given three I tied that game right
then I picked Tampa Tampa against
Atlanta getting eight and a half I
[ __ ] won that game
I had Greenbay given seven
whatever-the-fuck against the hapless
[ __ ] Cowboys right - oh and one
nobody's gone undefeated
I had the [ __ ] Kansas City Chiefs
those [ __ ] [ __ ] won the goddamn
game and just decided to give it away
ah I really want to blame the [ __ ]
refs but it that [ __ ] Matt Cassel he
just he just drove me [ __ ] nuts those
[ __ ] receivers not catching the ball
kid [ __ ] the Kansas City Chiefs [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] do you see that [ __ ]
call Chiefs fans you see do you see that
pass interference call
the end of the [ __ ] game when the
Raiders were down by 2 I can see this is
why I think it's fixed and this is why I
think I'm good I would never gamble
other than just with a buddy like I
don't I honestly I don't know how you
[ __ ] gamblers do it because the level
of [ __ ] emotions that you go through
when you have money on the game is
nothing nothing compared to you just
love in your hometown teen all those
[ __ ] douchebags who go out to the
Raiders game maybe they [ __ ] dress
like Spock or whatever the [ __ ] it is
Spock with like spikes coming out of
their shoulders as much as they think
that they give a [ __ ]
you know you don't give a [ __ ] as much
as some guy who's not even from Oakland
who's got money on that [ __ ] game I'm
telling you why the [ __ ] levels so
goddamn low
think it's time to get a new recorder
here people have been bitching a little
bit saying the levels are a little bit
quiet here got to make sure I've got
this [ __ ] going here hello test one
there we go alright so anyways when that
[ __ ] ref called that pass
interference and then they show the
replay and the announcers are just like
oh let's see what's going on here
doesn't seem to be any contact lil G
Mike I'll tell you I didn't see anything
and then they just continued on nobody
starts going well why defy the [ __ ] do
you call something that didn't even
happen you know I mean I can see missing
some [ __ ] that happened it's like
[ __ ] 22 goddamn people out there
running around how the [ __ ] he's
supposed to see everything but how do
you call some [ __ ] that didn't even
[ __ ] happen I swear to God I think
it's [ __ ] fixed on some level
something [ __ ] up is going on and I
challenged my listeners all right you
[ __ ] defend that how is it hot you
know look it sound like something
[ __ ] who lost money on a [ __ ] game
how do you call some [ __ ] that didn't
happen I get it 22 [ __ ] people I get
how you can miss something it's like
standing in Grand Central Station
everybody's going every which way
something oh my god do you see that then
homeless guy just took his [ __ ] on the
floor did you see that actually I didn't
I was staring at that chicks tits I
missed it
I get that but how do you call that I
[ __ ] 15 yards for [ __ ] on the
floor and there's no [ __ ] on the on the
floor that's that's a stupid [ __ ]
example this is how matter I was so
[ __ ] mad when the refs missed that
goddamn call and gave in a [ __ ] did
mr. call just invented that [ __ ] call
gave the [ __ ] Raiders a first down
and then I see that that fat [ __ ] dude
who got caught with the date rape drug
warming up his leg and I know he can
kick it from [ __ ] Siberia so items
like this game's [ __ ] over is gonna
go into OT and I shut the game off and I
just I picked up the remote control and
I just started [ __ ] just just just
slamming it methodically like that
[ __ ] Slingblade guy I'll write it
down on Dwight Yoakam [ __ ] head just
just I actually I got so [ __ ] mad I
died out of just courtesy to my girl I
just I walked I grabbed my [ __ ]
hoodie and I just started walking
started walking up the street like [ __ ]
I didn't know where I was going
Tourette's [ __ ] God get [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] refs no [ __ ] way [ __ ]
you [ __ ] cause something that didn't
even [ __ ] happen I should be 301
[ __ ] people walking by with their
pugs just staring at me I'm trying to
act like I'm talking on my cell phone
I'm not talking to myself I'm talking to
that [ __ ] ref that piece of [ __ ] ref
I swear to god if I was running the
[ __ ] league and at the end of the
game some [ __ ] ref made a goddamn
call that that overtly affected the
point spread and he made a call it
didn't even [ __ ] happen that son of a
[ __ ] would be in my office Monday
[ __ ] morning I'd have his phone bill
laying on the table his Visa MasterCard
bills his [ __ ] passport all of his
[ __ ] and I would be looking at his life
and I would figure out who the [ __ ] this
guy owes money to that you can make a
horseshit call like that alright I'm
back that's what happened to me I
[ __ ] walked up the hills so goddamn
pissed I started walking into the
goddamn Hills
walking up to the street and that the
sun's going down right I get to the top
of the goddamn hill and I realize I'm
right at the foot of this [ __ ] park
that has a bunch of goddamn coyotes you
know and I'm night I'm not there I'm not
there with my [ __ ] pit bull I don't
have my security with me and I'm just
walking up there and I was thinking like
Jesus Christ what if I get mauled to
death
by a pack of coyotes that would be the
dumbest death ever comedian mauled to
death by coyotes because the Chiefs
didn't cover against the Raiders and
right there I was just like you know
what this gambling [ __ ] is the dumbest
[ __ ] you could ever do to yourself if
you've never gambled don't do it
don't put money on a game it literally
it ruins your football Sunday it [ __ ]
ruins it it's losing money on a game I'm
telling you is so much worse than just
watching your team lose you know your
team loses they [ __ ] lose but you
still you can still go out and go buy
yourself a slice of pizza right you know
maybe that keychain you had your eye on
alright that's enough that's enough with
the sports this [ __ ] week I believe
um so congratulations to the Co the
Cleveland Browns
fans I'm actually in some weird way it's
kind of hard cuz you beat my team I'm
actually excited that you guys look like
maybe you finally picked the right
quarterback after years of you know the
Cleveland Browns are so kind of like the
Chicago Bears of the east you know were
they just I don't know they they always
get that Cade McNown Tim Couch or
whatever the [ __ ] his name I they always
get that guy that guy who was the fifth
runner-up Heisman Trophy guy you know
and they did it again this year with
Colt McCoy and he looked great he
[ __ ] looked great stepping up into
the pocket ran one for a touchdown he
was [ __ ] rolling out throwing the
ball on the run like [ __ ] Doug Flutie
I don't know whatever what the [ __ ] he
gonna do god damnit we got raped
we got raped in Cleveland right next to
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame just to
add insult to injury and then I got to
get all these emails from these Jets
fans you know they were all laying in
the [ __ ] weeds just waiting for the
Patriots to lose you know I was amazed
at how quickly I got the email sometime
considering they had to clean four
quarters in one oh t of [ __ ]
they're pants if you are gonna if you
are gonna gamble I got to tell you the
the cat might be out of the bag but
there's I love teams right now like
Cleveland the Lions who else this was
one other one the Rams
if those teams are on the road and
they're getting any sort of sizable
points I would go with those guys just
because they have competitive [ __ ]
teams like they just Lions had a great
[ __ ] draft and they could they keep
being like [ __ ] five point underdogs
and that type of [ __ ]
I don't know then they blow it in the
[ __ ] and that's the only thing
because if they let up a touchdown then
you lose it's all [ __ ] fixed how
could it not be fixed how did you know
how do they pick the perfect [ __ ]
number every goddamn week how do they do
that
you know if it's so [ __ ] hard for me
I I don't get it like I'd literally be
like if I picked one game a week I
should have a 50/50 chance of winning it
right and after 1617 weeks with the by I
should be you know 500 won game over one
game under right I should be nine and
eight or eight and nine and it never
works out that way somehow you you lose
like 60% of the [ __ ] time I don't get
it there are any mathematicians out
there they can [ __ ] help me out I'm
all goddamn ears that piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] ref this is what happens to when
you gamble then you start [ __ ]
knowing the names of referees and that's
when you have a [ __ ] problem you
start knowing the names of backup
punters I guess some people know that
[ __ ] nowadays those fantasy football
playing people do that kind of my my
fantasy team what a [ __ ] are my
questions for the week all right that
was 20 minutes of sports I really good
let's let's talk politics talk let's
talk politics the elections were this
past week where are you guys excited are
you excited that we took the country
back how many times are we gonna do that
in these elections you know like two
years ago I remember everything was the
Republicans fault and then they vote in
all Democrats and people like yeah we
took the country back right
- here's [ __ ] later they vote in all
Republicans and they say the exact same
[ __ ] thing this is the theme this
week is that everything is [ __ ]
rigged you can't tell me you you can't
you don't notice that no matter who you
put in now it doesn't really make a
difference that this sort of this this
common they're towing this the same line
anybody anybody noticed that none of
them are talking about bankers and how
they took a trillion dollars no one's
talking about that and just kept the
[ __ ] no one's talking about that no
one's talking about how all these
companies have [ __ ] taking all the
manufacturing out of this country we
probably need to reverse NAFTA that'd
probably be a good [ __ ] idea no one's
talking about that that
democrat-republican the algae's I think
it's time to get this guard feedback to
work everybody starts screaming like
something's gonna [ __ ] happen
you know Federal Reserve just printed
another six hundred million dollars out
of thin [ __ ] era's buying up bonds
it's nobody's then nobody's talking
about that [ __ ] nothing nothing all
they're talking about is [ __ ] Family
Values and getting people back to work
and hardworking Americans and all this
lip service you know and then people
vote Democrat a Republican right which
is your [ __ ] right but then whenever I
tell them I voted for somebody outside
those two parties who actually says hey
why don't we audit the Federal Reserve
why don't we figure out why they're a
private corporation
yet somehow print the money for this
country they always tell me that that's
a waste of a vote so then you vote for
[ __ ] I don't get it I really don't
[ __ ] get it so I'll give this [ __ ]
this whole country's going down the
[ __ ] [ __ ] everybody's just sitting
there yelling at each other [ __ ] tea
party screaming at people I could give
it thought you know I just find the
whole thing unbelievably
[ __ ] depressing I think the world is
run by sociopaths and who manipulate
morons you know you got this whole sea
of morons could fill up the Pacific
Ocean with the amount of morons you know
tell me what to think those people and
then the sociopaths tell them what to
think in whoever's the best at telling
them what to think
wins gee bill that was [ __ ] deep I
know I don't know if the [ __ ] I'm
talking above you know what it is I just
like the people who
uh I don't know I I got my man explain I
just slides us like people who just go
this this is [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] fixed I like those guys
I don't like people who go you know you
know we're the Jesus you know what this
podcast went off the [ __ ] rails at
least three minutes ago I don't want him
so you know I'm so [ __ ] stupid that I
don't even realize that I'm one of those
morons in the Pacific Ocean that here--a
I'm trying to have this deep [ __ ]
thought about politics and I don't even
have the [ __ ] wherewithal the
brainpower to even convey my own
thoughts so with that let's go with the
obscure sports stat of the week this is
a new this is for all the the sports
nerds out there this is the obscure
sports stat of the week this is a new
segment all right this is something I
didn't realize is how much teams from
Massachusetts from Boston have dominated
st. Louis here's the gist I was in st.
Louis two weeks ago and somebody hit me
with hit me with this stat all right
well the last time the st. Louis
Cardinals lost a World Series they lost
to the Boston Red Sox the last time the
city of st. Louis lost a Superbowl they
lost the New England Patriots the last
time the city of st. Louis lost a
Stanley Cup Finals game they lost to the
Boston Bruins and the most obscure of
obscure the last time st. Louis lost an
NBA Finals in 1960-61 the st. Louis
Hawks lost to the Boston Celtics
we [ __ ] own you guys st. Louis you
hear me we've owned you since 6061 and
what have you done about it
nothing all right I'm bored shitless
with sports too let's let's move on here
um what do we got here Oh last week I
asked you guys you know I was talking
about that woman who kept clearing her
throat in a really annoying way behind
me on the plane and I I presented this
question to you I said what would happen
if the most interesting man in the world
met the most annoying woman on the
planet what would happen and I asked you
guys for your theories and I got a bunch
of them and I'm gonna try to read them
now and not [ __ ] it up this is what
people had to say without saying a word
he can make even the biggest [ __ ] and do
the [ __ ] dishes because he is the
most interesting man in the world
all right that's theory number one
theory number two most entering most
interesting man plus [ __ ] eosin
equals most miserable man that's pretty
much it bill
that is if your question implied an
inherent and attraction between the two
if it's just like a chance encounter
like at a party or something like that
the most interesting man would probably
just say you're such an annoying [ __ ]
and he'd be on his merry way however if
the two decided to form a relationship
the most annoying woman would just
siphon everything interesting away from
the most interesting man
chiseling him down to a being that could
equate her level of unjustifiable
existence and then he rates Wow that's
depressing
someone should advertise some PSAs or
something there is no shame in a
harrowing hunt so please do not settle
for an annoying [ __ ] I'm brought to you
by the people who hate kunti throat
clearers allocated to their immediate
ear space all right let's move on with
YouTube videos for the week I'm gonna
blow through some topics here just for
some people because I really I got a I
got a tone down the sports on this
[ __ ] thing it's just becoming the
[ __ ] beer and wings podcast here
YouTube
YouTube videos of the week look at
garbage day original all these by the
way will be up on the mm podcast.com
look at garbage day original and this
one right here this one is from me
and I think this is one of the greatest
[ __ ] lines ever uttered in in movies
ever certainly and err any sort of teen
movie that was that's about teens
rebelling this movie is called over the
edge I believe it came out in 1979 oh
it's over the edge 1979 part nine and
and just looking at that and you know I
also started off with Revenge of the
Nerds that speech on this podcast it
kind of made me just think of some
classic movies good and bad here's L
look up Al Pacino great ass extended
version one of the greatest actors of
all time with one of the worst
performances I've ever seen in my life
and what else do I got incident at
Subway check that one out some kid at
Subway wants to fight every somebody
behind the counter yeah Jesus I don't
know what's going on um neato uh what
else underrated overrated what happened
to this podcast something at 22 minutes
happened at this podcast you know what
it is as I went outside I'm still
wearing my [ __ ] hooded sweatshirt and
I think I'm getting too [ __ ] hot and
it's siphoning all the goddamn funny out
but now I can't take it off cuz I have
my [ __ ] headphones on so I got to lay
the microphone down as I slowly take
this alright here we go
now I'm ready oh I remember what I was
gonna do I was gonna tell you guys the
story this week I did this awesome
unbelievable [ __ ] gig
it was the Bob Woodruff Fund whatever he
call
not Jesus Christ I really thought that
this story was gonna get the podcast
going again what the [ __ ] was it called
the Bob Woodworth
charity fund auction thing Bob Woodward
is a reporter he was in Iraq he got hit
by a roadside bomb made a miraculous
recovery and this is the 4th annual one
where they raise money for his
foundation that's the word I was looking
for his [ __ ] foundation to raise
money for it for you know for troops
who've been injured in battle on that
type of thing just one of those those
those charities you just cannot say no
to you have to do it and it was all the
way back in New York City at the Beacon
Theater for music fans out there they
know that the Allman Brothers have been
doing the beacon run for like the last
thirty [ __ ] years so already I'm
thrilled to be there just because I'm
gonna be standing on the same stage as
Duane Allman and
and I showed up in the lineup that I
went on was the most insane lineup I
have ever been on in my career this was
the lineup all right Max Weinberg was
there and he put together this big band
so they're out there [ __ ] killing it
Jon Stewart was the host he goes out and
he kills it talking about politics in a
very funny way
unlike the horseshit that I did on my
podcast he [ __ ] kills it
then he brings out Tony Bennett Tony
[ __ ] Bennett who sinks two songs
absolutely kills it sounds as good as he
did 4050 years ago just kills it then
they bring out John Stewart comes back
out does some more jokes kills again
then he brings out Bruce Springsteen
[ __ ] Bruce Springsteen goes out there
and just [ __ ] owns two stage sliding
around jumping up on the piano tells and
telling jokes just just [ __ ] kills it
then they had an auction at least
[ __ ] rich people's played like a
hundred fifty grand for one of Bruce
Springsteen's guitars raised all this
money then the second half for the show
they bring out joel mchale who went to
go on after Tony Bennett and [ __ ]
Bruce Springsteen and he still somehow
killed it then I went up and then the
final act of the evening was Jerry
Seinfeld once the do Jerry
[ __ ] Seinfeld the King the master
right and I'm on stage when I went out
there and my whole nervousness of the
night was not going on after those
people was my nervousness was the fact
that nobody had said [ __ ] yet and it was
a benefit you know and people talking
about tragedy and I was gonna go out
there and my opening bit was talking
about you know hitting women
so I'm backstage just like mine [ __ ]
myself going ah god it's gonna be too
harsh
I shouldn't curse Jerry's gonna get mad
at me the second I curse he's gonna look
at me like I'm not even a comedian you
know and I so badly want his [ __ ]
approval
you know
so I'm sitting there freaking out
finally my agent just goes dude you see
what Springsteen just did he went out he
just does what he does jumps on pianos
just go out there do what the [ __ ] you
do I was like you know what you're right
you're right so I went out there right I
definitely I didn't say [ __ ] as much as
I usually did but I went out there I did
my get you know hit by women hitting
women all that type of [ __ ] it [ __ ]
killed and when I get offstage I'm
walking and Jerry's going on next so I'm
walking off the stage and there he is
[ __ ] Seinfeld who at this point it's
like it's like looking at Elvis goddamn
icon he's standing there in his suit
just ready to go to work and I walked by
him I'm just I'm just wincing when I'm
waiting for me just completely blow me
off or just be like why did you say [ __ ]
so much you know and I walk by him and
he [ __ ] sticks his hand out and he
just goes really funny stuff really
really funny stuff and I was just like
oh thanks a lot you know I try not to
curse so much out of respect for you
going on going on next and it goes I
don't care
then I felt like an idiot I'm sitting me
and I'll nervous like a little
schoolgirl now I just realized like wait
a minute Jerry is always work totally
[ __ ] clean he came up in the late 70s
right through the 80s with all these
these barroom hack comics doing blow I
mean the amount of [ __ ] that that guy
had to go on after working squeaky
[ __ ] clean he can't follow me well
what the hell was I thinking no I think
it he couldn't follow me I didn't
thinking that he would be annoyed and
then I stood there you know like feeling
like I was 90 miles in the air because
he said that he thought that I was funny
or that I had good stuff and then I
watched him go out there and it just
absolute
to bring up sports again but I guess I
have to you know any port in a [ __ ]
storm here it was like watching you know
what somebody's just just has that just
the perfect swing perfect jump shot
their form or whatever that that's what
it was like there was just everything
that he did there wasn't one wasted word
one wasted movement every everything
okay you want to talk moves it's like
Toy Story you go to see Toy Story it's
like every line in the movie just
propels the thing forward there's not a
line of fat in that [ __ ] script and
it's just just like his act and he goes
out there and just just absolutely
[ __ ] destroyed and it was awesome the
other another night that I had that ever
compared to that was one night I was
down at the Comedy Cellar in the and the
village in New York City and that's the
club where if you want to see go out and
see great comedy or if you want to see
possibly somebody super famous
that's a comedian just drop in and do a
set that's where I would go and it used
to happen all the time and one night I
was down the cellar and give me a name
and a lot of names here but I never
named names of the podcast but there's
nothing bad about this story so Godfrey
was hosting the show and
you know I was supposed to I think I
think was me I was going on next but all
of a sudden you know
I'm I can't really tell the story
without saying the names this is
basically just imagine you're sitting in
the [ __ ] crowd all right you're just
seeing no-name hacks like me going up
and all of a sudden the host goes uh hey
everybody we got a very special guest
that just dropped by wanted to do like
five minutes you might recognize this
guy from the hit TV show Everybody Loves
Raymond please welcome Ray Romano and
Ray walks on stage and the crowd goes
[ __ ] nuts holy [ __ ] Ray Romano right
and as he's onstage Seinfeld and Chris
Rock show up and they also want to go on
all right this has happened once in 20
years of me doing stand-up this was the
most unbelievable night right so they go
downstairs Ray Romano finishes so
Godfrey goes back up and he kept doing
these great intros that was making the
crowd lose their [ __ ] he goes keep going
forever Monty goes all right we got
another special guest just dropped in
you might recognize this guy from the
Chris Rock Show please welcome Chris
Rock and then the [ __ ] place standing
ovations holy [ __ ] we got a [ __ ] Ray
Romano and Chris Rock and now at this
point every comic knows that Seinfeld is
waiting in the wings so we're all
standing there huddled down in the
little hallway waiting to watch this
crowd lose its [ __ ] [ __ ] like those
soccer moms on [ __ ] Oprah right Chris
Rock kills it Godfrey goes up Chris Rock
everybody crowd is like out of breath
from [ __ ] laughing and then he goes
we had another guest drop by at this
point people just like what the [ __ ]
right he goes you might recognize this
next guy from the hit TV show Seinfeld
and I had this guy go no [ __ ] way
and he goes please welcome Jerry
Seinfeld and like half the crowd almost
fainted he goes up and just [ __ ]
destroyed
and like people are like elated they
have like like when he's done they
everybody's faces just like in pain from
grilling and from from from grinning I
swear to god this is true story right so
Seinfeld ends and he goes I keep it
going for Jerry Seinfeld he goes alright
you guys ready for more show the crowds
like flipping out and they go okay this
next comedian and the crowd at this
point is so goddamn spoiled I'm standing
there in the doorway waiting to go on
and everybody is trying to look around
my head for somebody famous to come on
and he's bringing up me he goes please
you know you might have seen him on
vh1's I love the 80s
[Music]
MTV's apartment 2f please welcome Bill
Byrne I went on stage and it was just
there was a noticeable sense of
disappointment at that point when I
walked up to the mic and the only way I
got out of it was I just addressed it I
was like that's right welcome back to
reality this is what the [ __ ] you paid
for and then everybody laughed and like
all right he addressed it he addressed
the fact that we're disappointed to see
him and at that point they kind of went
along for the ride and I swear to God an
hour later Dave Chappelle went up and he
went up and that was thought so that
night and the night I just did with the
two two most unreal nights that I've
ever seen in in stand-up comedy I swear
to God that cellar story I know it
sounds like some [ __ ] I swear to god
it's [ __ ] true and I don't know why
I'm thinking that you're doubting it so
if you ever go to New York City and you
just want to go out and check out some
[ __ ] comics go to the Comedy Cellar
right down on West third and McDougald
right I've said that like 9 million
times in my life
flagging down a cab back in the day when
he could do eight sets on the weekend
every night flagging down the cab with
your spot money
take me to West third and McDougald do
you want me to think these be the
highway no you [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
gonna cost me an extra $7 okay there's a
lot of traffic
all right you dick [ __ ] take the
other one your son of a [ __ ] what do I
care
what do I care someday I'll have my own
podcast and I'll be selling ringtones at
$0.99 a whack just raking in the [ __ ]
money all right let's get to underrated
overrated for this week all right this
first underrated overrated that I'm
gonna read is this goes this transcends
the topic of underrated overrated
because what you really not only do you
get to hear this person is underrated
overrated you get to see why having a
tragic childhood and I don't know I
don't know what a yeah basically that
leads you to be [ __ ] hilarious
because all right let me just read this
[ __ ] this is this is from the same
[ __ ] person all right underrated your
new girlfriend being hotter than your
ex-girlfriend
that first face-to-face meeting between
them is priceless
that's right she's hotter and skinnier
than you enjoy the the eating disorder
you [ __ ] so right off the bat you think
it well that's kind of harsh the [ __ ]
where does that come from you learn
where this comes from and is overrated
overrated your dad telling you he loves
you
I heard you [ __ ] I'm not saying it back
now tell that fat [ __ ] you left mom for
to get me a fresh beer now I'm going to
tell you right now if this dude ever did
stand-up he would be the guy that the
comedians hang in the back of the club
watching onstage as the crowds groaning
laughing their [ __ ] ass off because
they're relating to everything that he's
saying those are two classics those are
two [ __ ] classics right there I heard
you the first time [ __ ] I'm not saying it
back just completely walled off with the
emotions ah that's [ __ ] great that's
a funny guy right there you already know
it you know what anyways underrated
modern horror movies being that it was
Halloween last week every channel had a
horror movie marathon of some sorts and
I watched some of them what happened to
horror films they used to be scary it
might be that I have grown up but I
think the real problem is that they
spend most of their time trying to gross
out the audience have you actually seen
the movie saw the first one was good but
after that they just trying to make you
throw up I mean does the movie really
need a two-minute sequence of a guy
being injected with acid and melting did
that really happen that's kind of why I
stopped watching I saw the first saw and
I thought it was interesting and I
started to watch the second one and I'm
like this is just gross this isn't
really scary it's like
it's like scary like no it's like an
even grosser jackass right does that
make any sense a phony just keep reading
this goddamned why am i trying this week
anyways he goes on to say it would be
okay if they were unpredictable but they
always make the killer the most obvious
choice choice which just makes it
obvious did that make sense
yes it did why did you lose confidence
in the end no I totally agree with you I
think the problem with a lot of movies
both action movies and horror movies is
that the special effects are so
unbelievable now that that's what they
focus on this happens this happens this
happens and then the [ __ ] special
effects that they don't build any
suspense
you know and they don't really build the
characters where you give a [ __ ] about
them and you're rooting for them do you
mana I just like mentally tap out of
most of them I'm like well this guy's
the lead so there's no way he's gonna
die or else the movie would be over so
what's the [ __ ] point of this and
like I always bring it back to a perfect
storm like I could give a [ __ ]
you know by the time they got to the
wave I was like rooting for the wave
because I I didn't care about their
their pathetic attempt to try to bring
some nobility to these guys who went
fishing
he's just so gloss over glossed over the
whole [ __ ] thing I had and didn't
even give a [ __ ] so I would agree with
you sir uhm what else we got here
underrated cane sugar seriously so much
better than that high fructose crap
Pepsi throwback is awesome you know what
I'm gonna try it just cuz you said that
and I'm not even a big soda guy
underrated going to a concert most
people I know have never been never had
the full concert experience of going to
see someone you love and seeing them
live on stage killing it and leaving
leaving deaf sweaty tired bruised and
loving every second of it you're
probably facing the same problem with
people going out to see stand-up
actually I got to be at MIT I've been
really lucky but lucky people have been
coming out to my shows but anyways he
says they think it's going to be the
same thing as watching it on TV I
remember the first time I saw you do you
stand-up act it was also the first time
I'd ever seen a comedy show I'm
paraphrasing because I don't know where
I am in this sentence
first time I ever saw a comic was you
about four years ago and the live
experience of seeing someone who was
good at their craft it's just so much
better than watching it on TV well thank
you very much sir it's considering you
just gave me a little bit of a pat on
the back I want to thank you everybody
who's gone out and has bought my DVD my
DVD is killing it it's still last I
checked it's still in the top 10 on
iTunes I can't thank you guys enough I
just want to sell an even better than
why do I do this sold and all the emails
you guys are sending me about that extra
21 minutes of material that you didn't
get to see basically 25% of the special
that he didn't get to see on Comedy
Central I read all of them I appreciate
all the all the kind emails and all that
type of [ __ ] it's nice it really offsets
all the jet fans giving me [ __ ] to read
a nice compliment now a jet fans gonna
write I love the DVD and I'm gonna open
it up Patriots suck I already know
you're up to that what do you think I'm
a [ __ ] child
but seriously and Christmas is coming up
so keep buying those DVDs it's only like
10 bucks on amazon.com and as I stated
before it makes a great stocking stuffer
for someone you don't give a [ __ ] about
but have to buy a gift for go out bang
out six of them for 60 bucks there you
go frisbee around there you go you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever up to
six people
you know whatever just buy the goddamn
thing okay my ringtone was such a
goddamn flop people actually asking me
to make another ringtone and I feel like
a band that's scratching their head why
they haven't been dropped by their label
yet which actually segues us into some
of the questions for this week if I
could find them somebody actually asked
me some drum questions so bill I got
three questions for you after I heard
your drum battle on YouTube and you
didn't suck you seemed like a relatively
good drummer an extremely good
opinionate er so I'd like to ask your
opinion on some drum things what do you
think are some of the hardest drum songs
to play well for me it would be just
about all of them I
the hardest ones I would say I would say
as far as like for okay I'm gonna get
actually get into this a little bit cuz
I really got hardcore into sports you
know not even remotely concerned about
people who could give a [ __ ] about
sports so I'll get into this a little
bit for the musicians out there is I
actually found one of the hardest things
to do is to have the discipline to just
sit down and try and make what I could
physically play actually sound good
cuz I think one of the one of the big
things when you're learning an
instrument is when you physically get
something down you move on to the next
thing you don't you don't stay with it
until you can actually make it sound
good
and make it sound good to somebody
listening to you play it you just okay I
got that down BAM okay now I'm gonna
move on to the next [ __ ] thing rather
than you know if you learn like a drum
fill you just get the fill down and you
play a couple of [ __ ] beats and then
you just throw it in yeah yeah I got
that down you don't really have it down
so one of the hardest things for me was
having a discipline and it was something
I learned when I was watching Steve
Jordan play drums and I was listening to
him play something and I was watching it
going I can physically play what he's
playing and what he's playing is
actually really simple but I could not
make it sound one-millionth as good as
he's making it sound right now like he
was playing a beat that would actually
be considered lame if I played it and
the way he played it it sounded
unbelievably fresh and it would make an
entire arena just start smiling and get
into whatever song was being played that
was the [ __ ] hardest thing as far as
trying to get halfway decent at drums
for me but as far as just songs that are
difficult any of this [ __ ] by John
Bonham his foot is just so goddamn fast
and you can catch up with speed but you
just can't play it the way he [ __ ]
plays it and I've had unbelievable
arguments about people like you know the
Coke and Pepsi argument with with white
rock drummers is who
like better bottom or Neil Peart this is
way back in the day before all these
these other kids came along and I just
[ __ ] killing it and I always picked
Bonham I didn't I didn't think Neil
Peart was anywhere near him
I thought Neil Peart was like a [ __ ]
technician he played right on the beat
and it was sounded very [ __ ] robotic
as opposed to John Bonham who could play
once again the simplest [ __ ] fill
that I could physically do but could
never play it the way he please did they
just ditch the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like
watching a great actor you know what I
mean who can just take like a really
just basic [ __ ] monologue and make it
the most interesting goddamned like a
Christopher Walken or even John Goodman
then I was playing like I find I forget
what a great [ __ ] actor that guy is
I don't know I don't know so but up as
far as like songs that I would say it's
difficult I would say the wanton song is
ridiculously difficult and I think most
people play it wrong they actually leave
out one bass drum note where he's
playing three in a row and they only
play two in a row at that [ __ ] tempo
was [ __ ] ridiculous out on the tiles
that second fill that he does that ends
where he plays a [ __ ] triplet with
one goddamn bass drum is [ __ ]
ridiculous
and then I also got omit that drum and
bass [ __ ] and a lot of stuff that like I
love really into like what's-his-face
Questlove the [ __ ] that he plays he's
another guy where I think he took like
the Steve Jordan thing to like the next
level
[Music]
and hehe does [ __ ] I don't know what the
[ __ ] he's doing but I don't like [ __ ]
stuttering here cuz I can't really think
of any specific song I'll give you one
here that I'm trying that I want to
break out my double pedal because I
don't play double bass I just play a
single bass drum but every once in a
while there's a drama comes along that's
so [ __ ] good it makes me want to play
double bass and I've actually really
gotten into that band Lamb of God and
just a warned some of my older listeners
this is that sort of that that Rob Rob
Rob Rob kind of [ __ ] singing but it's
not as bad as some of the other guys but
they got this song called break you and
this does a double bass pattern in the
end that I just think is the [ __ ] I'm
sure all you guys who play double bass
this is a [ __ ] joke for you but this
is something this is the kind of [ __ ]
that makes me want to play double bass
let's see if I got this here I can get
this just sounds ridiculous the way he's
singing all right here we go listen to
this [ __ ] double bass pattern this is
Chris Adler this is one of my new
favorite drummers I think this is the
[ __ ] right here listen this here we go
that [ __ ] right there that [ __ ]
machine gun [ __ ] actually figured out
what the [ __ ] he's doing but I that just
amazes me that the entire ban could be
on [ __ ] point like that and I know
you guys are gonna hit me with a bunch
of other double bass drum players who
are faster or whatever
I like their band because the temple
that they play it it's still [ __ ]
music to me because some of those other
bands I try to get into them but it's
maybe my ear isn't ready to hear it but
the [ __ ] is so [ __ ] fast dad it loses
its effectiveness that it stops being
music it just sounds like a jet
that's like flying by but never passes
my ears it's just sitting there in my
[ __ ] ear so uh I guess that type of
[ __ ] does that make any [ __ ] sense
what did I do what did I do let's get to
the next question who are some of the
best recent drummers
of the past decade I'll just tell you
the guys that I like I like everyone
from whoever played with those original
Chuck Berry's I like Ringo Charlie Watts
Phil Rudd Alex Van Halen Steve Gadd
Vinnie Vinnie Colaiuta Steve Steven
Adler Chris Adler quest there's so many
[ __ ] guys and I'm going [ __ ] blank
on all of them I really should have made
a list you know what I'll actually sense
to the mm podcast I'll send you a couple
of YouTube videos of some guys that I
think are just [ __ ] amazing amazing
drummers but uh I know anybody who gives
me the [ __ ] chills when I listen to
him and then that that's like the big
thing and they make me wish that I could
[ __ ] do it that's that's how I judge
whether a drummer's good enough if they
if they play some [ __ ] and it's so
[ __ ] good that in my delusional head
I start driving down the street
fantasizing that I'm doing it you know
during the middle of the greatest HBO
stand-up special performance ever then
then then that's I get into uh I get
into that drummer all right number three
is good times bad times the only song
that you can play I can barely play that
song but now this I can play some other
ones I don't know did that boy this [ __ ]
out of you music people who gives a [ __ ]
alright advice this is gonna be the last
thing and I'm gonna get on with my day
here advice spill how's it going I hope
that wherever you're at
everything is going swell lol alright
it's kind of a question about a
relationship here's my story I'm 19
years old 19 year old female who's been
dating a 20 21 year old male and we've
been together almost five years old five
[ __ ] years and she writes [ __ ]
ridiculous [ __ ] ridiculous I know and
our relationship has had its ups and
downs like any relationship but lately I
feel like I can't stand them anymore
oh yeah that's understandable even
dating I'm like half your [ __ ] life I
don't know what's wrong with me or maybe
you
I don't know what's going on I have no
[ __ ] clue but he seems to have a
really big problem with weed if he isn't
high he can't think about anything else
but getting high oh god here we go
his goal in life is to get high as a
[ __ ] kite and giggle that's a
peaceful nice [ __ ] goal
she writes what the [ __ ] I don't want to
be dating a weakling who needs a drug
like who needs a drug like that I want a
man and I don't know how to tell him
that every time I tell him I have a
problem with the weed we get into a huge
argument and I end up being the [ __ ] I
just want him to care about me more than
he cares about his weed and it's hurting
us financially we both only make 300
bucks a week and he's spending 75% of
his check on weed cigarettes and gas I
am the breadwinner I don't want to be
the breadwinner I'm so tired of taking
care of his dumb ass he doesn't even
seem like he's willing to change even a
little bit what do I do
I know I probably sound like a complete
prude but I'm not at all well anyways I
really hope you read this and can give
me some good advice all right
ma'am you are dating a [ __ ] loser
[Laughter]
yeah you're dating a loser
so yeah you got it you got to get out of
it I mean the only red flag in there is
when you said I just want him to care
about me more than he cares about his
weed now
the only question I have there is well
what if he was really into playing
guitar would you then be like I just
wanted to care more about me that he
does about his guitar playing because
then you know that's actually a red flag
with you because you could be one of
those awful people like one of the worst
relationships you can seriously be in is
when you're dating somebody who finds
your passion to be a threat and then
they systematically like they try to
mindfuck you out of basically either
your dream in life all the way down to
just a simple hobby that you have just
because it steals focus from you paying
attention to them which I don't think
you are in this I think you sound very
rational you actually said I don't know
if it's me so I don't think you are
being like that so I have to side with
you 100% here all right
let's for this first of all we'll start
with your relationship and just just
completely ignore the fact that he's 21
year 19 you've been together for five
years which means when you got together
you were 14 he was 16 which means at
some point he was 18 and you were under
18 so there was some sort of statutory
rape going on there right we'll ignore
all of that and just get to the fact
like you know I bet a lot of my
listeners would probably think that I
was gonna trash you for you saying that
I am the I'm the breadwinner I don't
want to be the breadwinner you know and
I and I would go oh typical [ __ ]
broads you know they all talk about how
they want to be the independent goddamn
woman and yada yada yada and all of a
sudden they gotta take care of some
[ __ ] sponge welcome to my goddamn
world I'm not I don't feel that's that
that you'll like that I know what you
see a date and a [ __ ] loser
you're dating a future subject on cops
it seems you know you had the way you
described him it's is he shirtless too
this guy's a [ __ ] loser he makes 300
bucks a week I'm not judging that aspect
of it but he spends 75 percent of it on
weed cigarettes and gas you know right
now I'm picturing that guy that Matthew
McConaughey played in Dazed and Confused
just hanging around the high school like
where the party's at man you know with
his cool car
yeah you got to get out of the
relationship you know and there's
nothing wrong as a female if if you know
I'm not saying that you go out and just
be a [ __ ] gold digger but you wants
your man to be able to provide that's
what the [ __ ] we do we provide we don't
provide we're useless we don't have a
womb right now seriously we're [ __ ]
useless so I uh I get it yeah you got
you got to break up with this guy you
mean how many times can you look already
it seems like you're approaching this
guy on eggshells
you know he'd be really nice if you you
know you just stop being a [ __ ] loser
you've been on again saying that you're
being a nice person so if I had to give
you any advice I would say you need to
get out of that relationship and
considering you've been in it since
you're 14 I think you might be a little
codependent and I think you need to
break up with this guy figure out who
the [ __ ] you are which will involve you
staying single for a significant period
of time and and just know that you know
breakups are painful just prepare
yourself for that so you don't go
running back to this [ __ ] loser and
waste another five years of your [ __ ]
life because you don't want to go
through six weeks of pain
just you know as they said in platoon
take the pain alright just get out of
the [ __ ] relationship and just just
tell yourself this is gonna suck for six
weeks I'm gonna wake up crying I'm gonna
feel lost I'm gonna be wondering what
did I used to do with all my free time
before I was with this person you're
gonna have that bizarre feeling where
now you're looking back on somebody who
was a huge party of life and now they're
becoming a stranger so then it just
becomes this weird episode like what was
that who was that what the was that my
life that just went into that [ __ ]
room for five years it's really but just
prepare yourself that that's gonna
happen but every day it gets a little
bit [ __ ] easier and then one day
you're gonna wake up you're not gonna
give a [ __ ] the sun's gonna be shining
and and then just enjoy being single
you're only [ __ ] 19 years old there's
no [ __ ] reason to be in a
relationship that's serious for that
[ __ ] long with the [ __ ] loser so
get out of it get through the pain and
then after six weeks you know just hang
out with your friends have a good
[ __ ] time but do not get into another
relationship I wouldn't get into another
relationship for like a year just be
single for at least a [ __ ] year and
feel how awesome that is to just be
single to wake up you know
feel good about yourself but then not
have to worry that someone else is a
douche
so that drags down you're feeling good
about yourself quotient and just [ __ ]
be single all right there you go I said
the same thing 90 times in a [ __ ]
role I realize it and what do we got I'm
a little over an hour here on the
podcast so good luck to you all right
that's it that's the podcast for this
week I will talk to you guys next week
this weekend I am at the funny bone in
Columbus Ohio and Friday Saturday and
Sunday are the dates that I'm gonna be
there actually those are the days here
are the actual dates November 12th 13th
and the 14th and on the 13th I'm gonna
try to go to that Ohio State Penn State
game you know because I've been to Ohio
State game but the first time I went
they played Bowling Green it was like
the middle of September one of those
cupcake games and it sucked so I want to
go there and get the full-on
horseshoe [ __ ] experience so that is
it thank you guys for all the emails
thank you so much for buying my DVD if
you haven't bought it yet
it's only ten bucks I swear to god
you're not gonna be upset if you buy
this [ __ ] thing and you really be
helping me out because I will get
another deal to shoot another special
that you can then watch and enjoy see
how it works
little surfs and [ __ ] turf here
beautiful all right I'll talk to you
guys next week
[Music]
you